hungary's prime minister viktor orban
says sanctions on russia have failed but
ukraine insists it can win the war as
its forces appear to be making some
gains in the east will the eu maintain
its tough stance and risk winter gas
shortages this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the programme i'm
bernard smith
hungary's prime minister says sanctions
against russia are not working victor
orban says a new strategy is needed one
that focuses on peace talks and
negotiations
in a speech in romania orban reiterated
his country which is a nato member will
stay out of the war in neighbouring
ukraine
hungary's economy relies heavily on
russian gas and the government in
budapest doesn't want to support
embargoes on russian energy imports
orban says since russia wants security
guarantees talks should be held between
washington and moscow not kiev
a new strategy is needed which should
focus on not winning the war but instead
on peace talks and drafting a good peace
proposal the european union's task now
is not to stand on the side of the
russians or on the side of the
ukrainians but to stand between russia
and ukraine this should be the essence
of a new strategy this is how the
situation is we are sitting in a car
that is a puncture in all four tyres it
is absolutely clear that the war cannot
be won in this way
ukraine will never win the war against
russia with american training personnel
and weapons
quite simply because the russian army
has asymmetrical dominance the second
fact that we have to face up to is that
the sanctions are not weakening moscow
the third is that europe is in trouble
in economic trouble but politically too
and governments are collapsing like
dominoes
only since the war the governments of
britain italy bulgaria and estonia have
collapsed and the autumn is not even
here yet the problem is that everywhere
in europe or in a large part of european
countries it is certain that there will
be a recession and this will cause
political instability
i have to say that if we would have been
a bit more lucky and if the u.s
president at this decisive hour would
have been donald trump and we had
managed to convince angela merkel not to
leave if donald trump would have been
u.s president and angela merkel german
chancellor the war would never have
started
but we didn't have luck so we are in
this war
we have to reach a new agreement with
the russians a new agreement has to be
reached between hungary and the chinese
and a new agreement has to be reached
with the united states it would be
easier with the republicans than with
the current democrats
now despite severe rounds of sanctions
russia's economy is still standing
moscow continues to receive billions in
revenue from energy exports some 20
european buyers of russian gas are
believed to have opened accounts in the
russian ruble
a kremlin decree in march required all
gas payments from what it called
unfriendly countries to be made in the
national currency
but some european energy companies are
voluntarily paying through russian bank
accounts saying the payments are in line
with eu sanctions
let's bring in our guests in vienna we
have roger hilton a defense fellow at
globe sec a security and geopolitical
think tank in the ukrainian city of la
vie we have michael buttercue a senior
fellow at the atlantic council and in
oxford samuel romani an associate fellow
fellow at rusi the royal united services
institute a warm welcome to you all
roger i'll start with you will europe be
able to maintain unity on ukraine as a
autumn and winter approaches
well good evening bernard and thank you
so much for having me before getting
started uh as we heard on the
introduction victor orban made a very
spirited speech that ukraine will not be
able to win this war so before we go any
further i just want to make the
statement that i vehemently disagree
with this position of the hungarian
prime minister i think a lot of the
cards are now are aligned for ukraine
long term to move forward in winning and
obviously goes without saying his
comments about europe needs to sit on
the side is also a position i don't
agree with uh the european union itself
is an institution based on values and
morals and right now it's not only a
moral imperative for the eu to act but
it's also in their strategic interest
when it comes excuse me when it comes to
the european union holding up yes of
course you you know you've had these
five governments that fall already but
it could be argued that they could have
fallen earlier and it took six months
for this to actually happen so while the
current implementation of the european
union strategy against russia isn't
perfect it has been impactful and i
think moving forward that it just needs
to be adjusted to move forward with the
battlefield policy moving on michael do
they see in ukraine what urban is saying
as a perhaps a commonly held view do
they worry it will become a commonly
held view in europe or do they think
orban is speaking on his own
i think a big fear here in ukraine is
that yes europe will become divided um
and that the interest in the war will
wane and that as pressure increases on
democratically elected governments in
europe and elsewhere
that um you know they will succumb to uh
you know the economic costs that are
happening but look it's very very
important uh for western governments to
uh keep together when it comes to policy
towards ukraine and then i have to say
as well that as a canadian it's very
important that countries like my own
stick to the sanctions they committed to
i was very very
disappointed and disillusioned when
prime minister trudeau recently watered
down his own sanctions in order to
return those generators for
north stream one back to russia so look
mr obama is one of the most dangerous
politicians on the planet he gave many
speeches recently some of them quite
racist he's an ally of russia so i you
know he's he's playing the russian
playbook and i don't think we can
believe much in what he actually says
samuel do you think uh europe will be
able to maintain unity over ukraine as
autumn and winter approaches the cold
weather comes
so i think that we need to look at the
question of european unity in several
different angles i think that certainly
european countries are going to continue
to supply arms to ukraine there are some
disagreements obviously with hungary not
wanting to be a party in the war and
also in bulgaria but the vast majority
of european countries are willing to
send artillery air defense systems and
other equipment so in terms of army
ukraine i think they'll certainly be
unity but where will get complicated is
on the next eighth package of sanctions
against russia will they move towards a
gas embargo there was a remarkable
coalescence of european countries on the
swift sanctions even on the oil embargo
after a testy period on individual
sanctions sanctions and russian entities
i think that that unity might start to
fray when it comes to natural gas even
big players like germany might bulk
we're seeing hungary already expand its
purchases of natural gas and keep
rushing nuclear energy so i think that
that will be the area
and also there will be divisions not
just between member states but the
biggest divisions will happen within
countries so between far right and far
left populist parties and the
governments that are in power so we need
to look at internal political cleavages
as being the biggest source of discord
for europe but i think the military
support will likely stay roger despite
his uh more outrageous statements victor
orban does have
challenges that are not unique in
european countries rising energy costs
heavy reliance on russian energy and
sanctions haven't particularly worked
have they russia's triple the amount of
money is earning from high energy costs
so does there need to be another look at
how we treat russia in this conflict
if i could just respond very quickly to
sam who brings up some good points i
mean i think for all of our viewers out
there it's very important to recognize
that since the beginning of july the
czech republic has taken over the
presidency of the european union and the
czech republic for all of our viewers
who might not know it are part of a
group that visigrad for which includes
hungary slovakia poland and the czech
republic and it's been very clear with
their new government moving on from
andre babish that they are going to
de-prioritize the platform of the v4 uh
sort of as a mechanism to coordinate
policy which was common before and then
also within that hungary has the
presidency of the z4 and the traditional
ally poland is obviously not in lockstep
with them
moving forward on to the next point as i
said in my earlier statements i think
the eu needs to adjust what's going on
now it goes without saying that when it
comes to energy different areas are
going to be are going to be more
vulnerable to others
obviously here just across the board in
slovakia they have major issues going on
but at the same time there are other
sources of energy coming in from the
south uh you know and you've had a bit
of an issue right now with the eu with
spain portugal and poland also saying
that the energy that they have they
might not redistribute it equally as was
proposed earlier in this week with
germany so i'm not here saying that
there's a quick fix to this but i do
think that there is a solution to be had
both on the political level and trying
to figure out how to maximize the gap
that europe does have access to without
putting too much money in the cost of
the russians at the same time
michael are you touching it before but i
mean there are over 5 million ukrainian
refugees across europe now
is there a concern that the welcome for
them
is waning
oh absolutely in fact i just finished a
tour of europe and um even in poland
which has been one of the strongest
supporters of ukraine uh this coming
september
seven hundred 000 ukrainian school
children will be admitted into polish
schools so that's a huge burden on them
we're staying in some other countries as
well that support for example free
railway tickets things like that are
being withdrawn and also people are
having a lot of refugees are having
problems um funding for example their
accommodation so it isn't an easy slog
but going back to the original point if
i may look i think your european
governments have to get their citizens
ready that they have to accept
short-term pain for long-term gain the
only thing mr putin understands is force
and if european countries begin to
buckle when it comes to supplying arms
to ukraine
or the strength of sanctions he's going
to go further and further into europe so
there can be no divides when it comes to
standing up to mr putin okay but um
samuel europeans particularly northern
europeans aren't used to having to put
up with short-term pain the eu
commission on those gas
gas shortages the commission wants huge
powers to mandate gas rationing and many
european countries already resisting it
uh do you think the eu will manage to
get that policy through
well i think that could be a bit of a
complicated uh measure we're already
seeing some nation states within the
european union normalizing the notion of
gas rationing i think there was a
statement coming from the german economy
ministry so robert habeck even several
months ago talking about that the
netherlands was also warning about that
at the same time so the idea that this
might be inevitable has been normalized
by existing governments but certainly
it's going to be very unpopular and it
risks emboldening uh the far-right
elements within those countries like the
wilder's type politicians in the
netherlands or inside uh germany the afd
or in italy now with mario draghi being
out removed the five star movement and
the legendary so
there i think that those concerns about
emboldening populists might prevent many
european countries from actually going
through to through on this and there'll
be others like hungary and slovakia
which i think that could drag their feet
entirely and veto such a measure and
roger what do you think about that is is
that going to work this attempt by the
commission to give itself these enormous
powers to to mandate gas rationing
if there's one thing that i think we've
all learned here is not to under
evaluate the grit the creativity and
also the policy grit uh of ursula
vondeline as president of the european
commission so i mean look it's i'm again
as i said earlier this is going to be a
tough decision but i think on the
political level a lot of people thought
that the massive bailout that happened
earlier in the 2000s that wasn't going
that wasn't going to happen and that
there was you know
talk about the greek economy and then
crashing out of the era so i do
wholeheartedly believe that given what's
at stake both in the short term medium
and long term that the deal will be had
will there be some tough pills to
swallow especially maybe among germans
absolutely especially now sort of with
the germany's 30 buy-in of juniper
there's no doubt that the energy sector
is hurting but as i said i mean when
there's a will there's a way and i think
moving forward especially with some of
the slovak uh slovak vice president
sethkovich is the president of the vice
president's commission i think there
will be a lot of momentum to try to get
this over the finish line with some
winners and losers but roger when you
say where there's a will there's a way i
mean there is resistance to this
particularly you know a lot of there's a
view that this is to save germany
and the greeks might particularly be a
bit upset about that considering their
uh request for fiscal leniency um years
ago during the financial crisis is that
view
does that view gain currency have
currency
i think for the moment it makes great
click date it's great headlines but at
the end of it and there are other uh
mechanisms within the european union to
try to get the ball moving forward as i
said i mean is it retribution is it a
bit as we say german shot and point it
it could be but i still think long term
without being you know we're still in
early days of this conversation
winter season is still a little bit the
heating season is still a bit of way uh
and i think it's not to be
underestimated the czech presidency the
role they'll play in it i mean very
famously i think it is their energy
minister who said if we have to we will
burn everything to stay alive and to
stay warm so again we're very early days
on this and i think moving forward there
will be compromise give and take and
we'll see what happens
michael are the further sanctions tools
uh that the europeans and the americans
and north atlantic countries can use
against uh russia that haven't been
employed that they should be considering
yeah i think so there are more uh banks
than can be sanctioned um i think um
the strategy though of using sanctions
to
cause perhaps harm or pain to the
russian people hoping that they'll rise
up against mr putin is not the right
philosophy to follow
i think
we have to get to a point and i know the
americans have been working on this is
to get other kind of slow starters on
board i'm talking about some of the gulf
countries uh um uae countries like that
because you know um as long as the
oligarchs or the people in mr putin's
circle can
hide their wealth or visit countries
like the uae or
countries in asia for example
they will not feel the brunt of the
sanctions we have to get to a point and
i said this before and al jazeera i
believe is that if these uh oligarchs
these people mr putin circle want to go
vacation anywhere they only have two
options one it would be perhaps north
korea and the others would be the
illegally made
island violence in the south china sea
by china so but you know these sanctions
take a lot of work they're not going to
be
employed overnight i think there's going
to be a lot of
bilateral negotiations for example even
with turkey which by the way is trying
to play meteor between ukraine and uh
russia uh they too are for example very
reliant on russian tourism so it's very
difficult for them to go all the way and
put in the really really tough sanctions
i believe samuel just on on what uh
michael was saying there has russia had
any diplomatic use success you think in
limiting europe's uh attempts to isolate
russia sergey lavrov's doing a tour of
africa at the moment after reaching that
grain deal the middle east isn't totally
behind uh
europe as uh as uh michael just said
that
well i think that russia may not have
necessarily been able to leverage its
relationships with populist parties or
inter-european divisions the extent that
they
would have thought and that is not
surprising because they've always
overestimated their ability to create
fractures within
european societies like i distinctly
remember speaking to uh russian
academics in 2015 a year after the
annexation of crimea and they were
telling me that they were shocked that
germany and many european countries
ultimately sanctioned russia because
they figured that their internal
connections would be able to have
prevented that outcome but outside of uh
europe the russians are doing quite a
good job at creating and moving towards
a post-western foreign policy certainly
china is backing so many of their
narratives whether they be on biological
weapons whether it be an aversion to
sanctions a so-called peaceful solution
that effectively means ukraine's seating
and sovereignty to russia india is
looking for new investments in the
russian economy most of the middle
eastern countries with the exception of
turkey and sometimes intermittently
israel have really been
on russia's side certainly accommodating
russia's positions and russia
strengthening its ties now in africa
with key countries like congo uganda
egypt ethiopia just on lavrov's tour and
in latin america too it was interesting
to see mercosur the summit not give
zielinski a speaking slot so russia's
post-western foreign policy is embracing
the multipolar order and its outreaches
to the global south have been much more
successful than some people may have
thought and their narratives too saying
the sanctions for example and not
russia's blockading of grain are causing
food insecurity those narratives are
going a long way in the global south the
west is encountering them effectively
all right roger is europe now having to
face up to the fact that it's operating
a war economy
uh bernard if i could just again sorry
uh if i could just respond to that i'm
really not if i'm just really not
convinced uh so wholeheartedly
of the success of russians you know soft
power outreach afterwards i think it
speaks massive volumes into you know two
recent sightings of putin's where first
turkey was in iran and just the sheer
fact that he was the one who's having to
wait for president erdogan you know
where he's the one who's always having
to wait was quite dramatic and then the
second is this really the main ally that
you know russia is so proud to trump it
out that they had a meeting with the
ayatollah when kiev can basically call
up anybody in washington or other g7
countries and have meetings with them uh
also when it comes to china again i
really think this is a veneer where even
you know the economy is hurting quite a
bit and i think that a lot of the
chinese companies whether it's import
substitution or financing they haven't
stepped in as much as i think everybody
thought they were going to for fear of
being dragged in the dragnet of
sanctions especially the given the uh
instability and the fragile fit of the
chinese economy i mean there's protests
going on right now in china
so if you could just repeat the question
sorry
well i'll i'll i'll carry on with this
theme then okay but even if you're not
convinced by russia's diplomatic uh
successes outside of europe
putin's not going anywhere is he
sanctions haven't destabilized him
haven't aren't threatening his removal
from power he might be playing a long
game he's he could be in there for a for
a long time he's not going to pull out
of ukraine
uh if i could just respond before my
colleagues i mean even if he is playing
a long game and again i don't agree with
the percep i don't agree with the
position that the economy is is okay
they're cherry-picking stats and when
you see whether it's in colombia there's
a sugar run uh or other issues where now
ladies are coming out without uh without
technologies and without the proper
technologies uh for airbags i think it
is very disconcerting and i think if the
silence is concerning that what are we
supposed to do with this import
substitution there's going to be a
massive hole in the deficit in the
budget moving forward as confirmed by
the finance minister and they're losing
a huge amount of the federal reserves
every uh their reserves when it's
sanctioned so again on the economic
level i think things are much worse but
when it comes to the eu yes
the system is set up that while it's not
great and presumably the evidence
suggests that we're going to be going
into recession and the cost of living is
going high which feeds into what sam
said about a lot of the populist parties
this is the reality we have to live in
and europe has gone through other big
crisis before all right michael uh is
putin playing the long game is he gonna
make do with the don bass or is it gonna
is is that enough of a face-saving
option
or
uh he's not threatened domestically he
controls the state media so no there's
no particular opposition there to public
opposition to what he's doing
what's the ukrainian view of how it's
going to play out
yeah definitely he's playing the long
game i mean let's not forget that this
war actually started in 2014 not on
february 24th of this year and then you
know in that time uh russia has been
inoculating itself against uh sanctions
for example with a tighter alliance with
china which is something they did even
during the pandemic when no one else was
traveling around so
they um they um you know the beauty of
being a dictator of course is you don't
have to uh face uh the electric on a
level
electric excuse me on a level playing
field um you can manipulate elections
you can get reelected and like president
xi try and stay in power for for life
but i do think the chinese uh i mean
kind of ally of russia at the moment are
much much more pro
sorry they're much more pragmatic and
that when they see that it's not to
their benefit that russia is warring
with ukraine and then also causing
trouble elsewhere in the neighborhood
for example in the central asian states
that they will uh pull further away and
then i think this is the wild card
bernard i think this is where
russia will be forced to re-evaluate um
its its strategy in ukraine but yes the
ukrainians um
need desperately much much more weaponry
and the main thing they need right now
because no inch of ukraine can be
considered safe including where i'm
sitting right now is they need the
ability to close their skies to those
long-range uh russian missiles that can
be shot from inside russia from a
thousand miles away yeah all right so
then uh uh samuel with the weapons that
nato is supplying to russia has russia
got the resources to keep fighting at
its at its current levels given the new
weaponry coming in
well that's always been an open question
how long could russia sustain itself i
mean there were british intelligence
reports they're predicting even back in
march and april that russia would burn
through its precision weaponry stocks
and that's why it was relying on kh22s
and a lot more uh poorer quality less
precise soviet air weaponry but i think
that that's less because they're running
out of stocks but more because they're
just trying to minimize costs and they
don't really care about the losses of
civilian lives i think that russia can
definitely continue fighting this war
for at least one to two years that's the
least the estimate is coming from
ukraine
even and also russia will be in
fortifying its defensive positions even
in places in southern ukraine so it will
potentially minimize some of its
casualties so even if it's losing
hundreds of people a day right now which
is what some reports are showing and is
burning through a lot of weapon stocks
we shouldn't underestimate russia's
long-term ability to continue
prosecuting this war though uh he mars
and other systems that nato was giving
to ukraine are a big advantage you're
still seeing anecdotal reports and
occurs on counter-offensive that russia
can still outgun ukrainian military by
eight to one in terms of artillery so
that's a big advantage that russia has
uh and roger so do you think has russia
got the resources to keep fighting at
its current levels in it and if so
is the the approach europe is taking as
you were saying at the beginning of the
program
europe should maintain the path that
it's on
i just seem to be in that position right
now where i i don't seem to be agreeing
a lot with that remaining just like sam
referenced i mean you had to richard
moore speaking at the aston security
conference you said that russia was
running out of steam before we move on
to sort of the european strategy at the
same time while sam made some good
points about them having these pillbox
brought in by lorries and you know don't
get me wrong this is going to be quite a
difficult take on the hair sun offensive
you know just yesterday you had the
american ambassador slovakia ambassador
bricks who was formerly the ambassador
to slovakia who said that the united
states support for ukraine will go on as
long as it's needed so if you have the
united states in that i think that sets
the tone for the rest of the countries
who will continue the ammunition and one
point that is not reported up enough is
while they still have the artillery
superiority in terms of the ratio for
the russians there are other long-range
weapon systems that the united states
could be providing that are even better
than highmars that would actually even
change the battlefield even more
drastically so it's not as if this is
the end all be all for the equipment
that can be shipped in
not to mention the massive security
training program that's going on in the
uk just today you had ben wallace in
slovakia looking into the other issues
when it comes to the eu i think finally
my position is they're going to have to
amend the strategy a little bit a little
bit of give and take and i think we saw
an example of that with the grain deal
well part of the incentive for russia to
get through the grains so that they
could get their fertilizer to market so
as i said moving forward the eu will
have to adapt all right gentlemen for
the moment we're out of time but thanks
to our guests to roger hilton to michael
bosaku and to samuel ramani and thank
you to for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com and for more
debate go to our facebook page that
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter we are at aj inside story
from me bernard smith and the entire
team here in doha bye
you